bonjour ma très chère amie
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur du snop à ma chère amie
coeur ravissement d'admirer une artiste
comme vous vous êtes vraiment une très
grande danseuse mais ce sont des
exercices
il faut que je m'entraîne beaucoup pour
réussir non pas 2 avec casimir
on ne dit pas ça cher ami pas de 2 est
un ballet avec deux personnages lorsque
vous êtes allé casimir vous seul danser
lui il se traîne moi je trouve qu'ils ne
se débrouille pas mal du tout il est le
sens du rythme c'est pas un grand
danseur mais je le trouve qu'il joue ou
non ce qu'il vous faudrait c'est
quelqu'un comme moi ce serait le
partenaire idéal avec la ford mais brave
pourriez-vous s'envoler dans les airs et
et il descend doucement il faut poser au
sol avec grâce
ah bon vous savez dans ces vous avez
appris après mes très chers amis
oubliez-vous à qui nous parlait n'ai pas
besoin d'apprendre gens de ma qualité
ont ça dans le sang et je me crois mais
est ce que je pourrais avoir une petite
démonstration mais où il mettrait
volontiers est un et makan mon chapeau
où puis-je me mettre là par exemple
c'est parfait qu'est ce que vous voulez
de musique à ce que vous voulez chers
amis je peux danser sur n'importe quelle
musique
alors attention
[Musique]
et
messieurs 10 ne voulait pas couper puis
à mais pas du tout ma chère amy je suis
en pleine forme je me suis seulement
arrêter parce que je pensais que cela
suffisait pour vous prouver l'étendue de
mon talent bravo c'était formidable
enfin casimir tu commences à avoir du
goût je suis très heureux que cela tu es
plus je n'ai jamais autant ri de ma vie
mais ce serait encore plus drôle si vous
aviez un nez rouge est un petit chapeau
de clown
tu n'as pas honte de moquer de moi de
parler de rire après l'exhibition que je
viens de faire
digne des plus grands opéras à ce n'est
pas un numéro comique il faut être
stupide pour le penser ah bon voilà
c'est beaucoup moins drôle
j'ai ramé que pensez vous de ces propos
injurieux monsieur du stop
il est très difficile de prendre parti
casimir et mon partenaire
bon vous ne voulez pas de moi mais ne
vous vexez pas mais je ne vais pas
chasser casimir non alors très bien j'ai
compris je n'insisterai pas je me retire
une fois de plus j'aime y restera un
compris au revoir je suis désolé
messieurs du stop
oui votre coeur et votre chapeau merci
monsieur du soir oui bon c'est quand
même à mon idée le nid rouge elle
chapeaux de clown
je ne répondrai pas à cette insulte pour
nudistes
il n'est pas plaindre hein chaque fois
que l'on fait un effort pour faire
quelque chose
il vient et prétend que lui peut faire
beaucoup mieux grâce à ses ancêtres il a
qu'à travailler comme tout le monde
casimir généré jamais remarqué que la
collecte grande et si philosophe
parfaitement raison mais en attendant
nous il faudrait nous entraîner si on
veut faire une fois parfaitement notre
danse un oui il faut que je fasse
quelques exercices d'assouplissement à
rabat oui mais alors aujourd'hui la
barre samba samba la barre s'en va et
c'est là par samba a alors tu met les
deux pieds bien serré bien parallèle les
bras le long du corps chouette tas
limpide et ouais t'es l'oublier weight
dalo plier derrière une baraque derrière
un ballon piqué turf et la médiation de
l'eau qui rouge ouais
elles ont plié bien plié de bruit potes
à l'oublier poite talons pliait bien
quand vous regardez chez vous pour
savoir en faire autant kazimi dont va
très bien pour l'avoir il a alors un
autre mouvement explique les bras comme
ça les doigts écartés
tiens mais toi face à moi pour mémoire
très bien et la crète bien tendu voilà
alors maintenant revient là est pliée
tendue au lit des templiers temps dû
plier tendue sur le côté la même chose
l'idée tendu plié tant dû plier tombe
diakite en dupliquant
comme si tu devais attaquer pied
l'enduit reste bien droit oui pis là
mais je derrière pied tendu qui
distingue ces deux bulles ap sera comme
sens du piéton dit très bien parfait
quand même bien devant côté derrière un
bon mais coûte la jolie je crois que ça
va je crois qu'on est prêt pas d'accord
on commence on va commencer la danse
alors musique
huawei
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]